[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
there's our first secret to you John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast about death
where two brothers Hank of John Green
and SIA questions give you to be his
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey
John how you doing I bet I bet you are
I bet are all those things my first book
in six years comes out in two weeks and
I am freaked out it is weird to have
nobody have read this book and not be
able to change anything and I freaked
out about going on tour and I am NOT I
would say like after having six or so
months of pretty solid health I am I'm
not all here how are you I'm good John
do you know I found out something about
myself that I didn't know before this
week I went into the foot doctor because
I have chronic pain and one of my feet
and half since high school when I pushed
a young man into a swimming pool
and broke my toe on him while doing it
and that's that's not super fun but so I
so I went and the doctor I was like hey
I have this problem because last time I
went in was like fifteen years ago and
they're like there's nothing we can do
so I didn't go back but it's been 15
years so maybe there's something they
can do now right as my sort of thought
and so the guy takes a bunch of x-rays
of my foot and and basically I come out
of it and he's like it's not really
anything we can do but but but but John
I have yes in my right foot the normal
number of bones like everybody else has
but not in the normal way oh so two of
two of my bones that should be two bones
are one bone oh you've had a bone nose I
thought I was born this way two of my
bones just were burnt like fused
together my pinky toe instead of being
like three bones it's two bones or
something
mmm so estimating that's a thing and
additionally I've just got like a Rando
bone that's floating in the middle of
my foot oh that's not connected it's not
connected to anything it's just like oh
there's one of those and I was like is
that normal and he's like now it's like
but is it like okay and it's like yeah
yes fine I was like you sure is that
like hurt me he's like nope just a Rando
bone so I got a I got a normal number of
bones but but accidentally because I
have one less than I should have and
also one more than I should have I mean
there's something metaphorically
resonant about that but I can't figure
out exactly what it is because yeah I'm
struggling to actively listen to you but
I want to actively listen to you not
primarily so the podcast will be good
but primarily so that I don't miss you
saying your phrase of the week yeah well
I'll give you a hint it was not Randall
Bowen okay very good a Finn no I thought
it might have been born this way the
wonderful Lady Gaga song and Hank if
ever you feel weird about your foot bone
situation I just want to remind you that
Lady gaga wrote a wonderful wonderful
song about being born this way and so
just listen to that if you're ever
feeling sad can I read your short poem
yeah please
alright this is by Emily brontë it was
sent in by listener Lauren thanks Lauren
and it's about autumn and it is kind of
autumn yeah much is here yeah fall
leaves fall die flowers away
lengthen night and shortened day every
leaf speaks bliss to me fluttering from
the autumn tree I shall smile when reads
of snow blossom where the Rose should
grow I shall sing when nights decay
rushers in a dreary ur day mmm and when
I think of the things that I own that I
am most proud of it's my one and less
extra bone I mean I'm not sure that
worked from a meter perspective but I'm
proud of you for thinking of a rhyme
speaking of which Alice has recently
gotten into rhyming but she can't she
doesn't rhyme correctly and it just
drives Henry bonkers so the other day
she was singing a song and the lyrics
were I'm walking in the hallway
I won't forget my mom me way and Henry
just said that's not right Henry you
don't get to decide how poetry works all
right Hank let's answer some questions
from our listeners this one came from
Bria and you know the more I thought
about it the less I knew the answer so
I'm just gonna ask it of you Dear John
and Hank as you know people are always
growing and changing a baby is smaller
than an old man it depends on the baby
but where does all the extra body come
from just love that phrasing there's so
much extra body and grownups versus
babies why don't why did they change
shape so much as you grow does your
extra bone just appear completely
useless at science or biology or
whatever this is categorized as Bria I
like how Bria starts the question as you
know people are always growing and
changing which I am like yes we learn
new things we find out that we the way
we once were is not the way that we want
to be anymore and it's just body come
from where you're proud of my bones bone
yeah oh they'll I mean we're talking
about bones a lot today on this podcast
of all the things I'm proud to own it is
my one extra and one less bone very
that's been and it's it's on the right
track and yet not there I'll give
working on it
your bones are alive just to be clear
they're not like they're not like like
rocks inside of you your bones are
constantly replacing themselves and
growing and fusing and and like when you
break them they're able to join back
together again your bones our living
tissue that is created by the cells of
your body so they are always as you grow
changing shape and that is done in the
same way that that all of your body
tissues change shape which is really
complicated and weird like so like I can
tell you that that there's nothing
special about boat like the way that
bones to it but also the fact that and
like all
your body's tissues do it is is in fact
very weird and we don't understand it
that well alright Hank while you were
talking I wrote out some I am BIC it's
not pentameter cuz it only has four feet
but just just to get it out of my head
to solve a problem you created in my
mind I wrote two iambic lines that rhyme
own and bone just to shut my brain up
and it is this okay of all the objects
that I own I'm proudest of my floating
bone okay good the only thing that I'd
add to that is that I actually find it
weirder that after growing for a long
time we then start shrinking mm-hmm like
my doctor recently said to me at my 40th
birthday checkup because of course the
how else was I gonna spend my 40th
birthday but I was like I used to be 6 1
as this is an ongoing argument between
Hank and me and my doctor said it is
perfectly possible that you used to be 6
1 and that you know the shrinking has
just begun or-or-or arms actually that
rhymes I'm gonna work on that one you
were just lying the whole time because
I've always been 61 and yet an inch
taller than you
this next question while John is working
on his poem comes from Jenny who asks
dear Hank and John I'm currently doing
my master's thesis in art history I find
my studies very interesting and feel
like I have chosen the right path
however parts of my thesis are dependent
on interviews from some very important
people in the art world and those those
words very important people are
capitalized I'm not usually scared of
talking to people vote and face to the
task of emailing very important people
and asking them to meet up with me to
help me with stuff I crumble in a ball
of anxiety will this ever go away
or will I have to be scared of talking
to important people in my field for the
rest of my life from the block Jenny
that's a good name certificate signing
off um I mean yeah it probably won't
ever go away what do you think Hank I
think it won't ever go away unless it
until you yourself become a very
important person it that does help
much whatever I still hang out with
people and I'm like yeah yeah yeah it's
like anything it depends on the pond
that you're playing in Madison ah alice
is certainly completely unimpressed by
what I do for a living so much so that
she insists that my job is racecar
driver and when anybody asks what I do
for a living she says my dad is a
racecar driver and when I tell her that
I am NOT a racecar driver she says but
you did do a race car race in Minnesota
which is true I did a race car race with
Maggie stevedore Hawaii author and I say
yes I was in that one race car race but
that does not mean that my job is race
car driver Alice and then she says you
got a trophy and I said I know I got a
trophy because Maggie Steve otter very
kindly let me win one of the races but
that still does not mean that my job is
race car driver my job is writing books
and making videos with Uncle Hank and
then she says your job is race car
driver it's fascinating but John do you
have advice for Jenny yeah but it's
gonna be dubious I feel like it's kind
of okay to be a little bit intimidated
when you're sending those emails because
you want to make sure that they are good
emails like you want to reread them and
make sure there aren't any obvious typos
and you want to have a certain level of
deference going into it but at the same
time you have to remember that these
people who are very important people in
their field even though my wife works in
art history I almost certainly haven't
even heard of them so just remember that
like you know outside of their pond they
are normal people and and so be you know
I think it's always helpful if you just
treat someone as if they're human you
express interest in their interest you
make it clear that you understand who
they are and what they do and you make
it clear why you want to talk to them
because you share an interest in the
field yeah and and in my experience of
interviewing important people who are
important either to me because of who I
like just who I am and what I'm really
into or because like like objectively
you know they are the current President
of the United States like that it's
terrifying and and the the thing that
goes into it and the thing that like I
had to fight for in those moments was
staying present and not being like this
is so weird this is so weird this is so
weird but just being like I am listening
to the words and I'm understanding the
words that you are saying right right it
would be very stressful to be the
president and to have essentially every
interaction you have with someone be
that person being like oh my god it's
the president oh my god it's the
president we have a question that from
Lucy who writes Dear John and Hank for
the last few months one question has
bothered me can jellyfish suffer that's
it that's the that's the whole question
she signs off the classic pumpkins and
penguins Lucy okay
Hank can jellyfish suffer weight is
suffering necessary wait I don't
understand I'd like to can ask it back
on question question yes suffering a
necessary part of life I don't think
that it's a necessary for one to suffer
no no is but so like single-celled
organisms don't experience suffering oh
ok I misunderstood your question I
thought you were saying like so given
that someone has the capacity to suffer
will they necessarily suffer I don't
think that that is the case I think that
it's very likely that if you have the
capacity to suffer that you will spend
at least some of the time while you are
alive suffering who who is this person
who didn't spend any time suffering I'm
not saying that the person exists I'm
just saying it's possible mmm a hardness
maybe and I really find myself disagree
maybe not a person maybe like a fish or
maybe like a dog or something that's
capable of suffering but never did stuff
like then unconvinced duper I'm gonna
register my disagreement and allow you
to go on all right and then as far as
like is suffering necessary for you to
be a living thing now it is a useful
tool but it I think that it's a fairly
fairly complex one certainly not like
it's certainly not anywhere close to the
most complex system that an animal can
have but it is I think that suffering is
I think my guess is that suffering is
outside of the capacity of a jellyfish I
guess is but but it's very weird it's
hard we don't know and we'll never know
like when we don't know what it's like
to be other organisms we don't know if a
tree can suffer in the same way that
like you know it's kind of like one of
the for me a condition of life is to
sort of want things and to take action
to move in the direction and to try and
acquire those things like that's sort of
like it's a good life definition and and
so if you're being prevented from
getting to that there are negative
feedbacks that that any organism will
experience I feel like suffering is one
of those negative feedbacks but I don't
think it's the only one and I think that
it's not one that every organism has but
I don't know because maybe is any
negative feedback saying like I am NOT
able to get to the thing that I want to
get to in order to survive or to
procreate and that is like I like
getting that negative feedback saying
like work harder figure it out you're
gonna die this is bad if any feedback
like that could be interpreted as
suffering right yeah it is a kind of a
question that asks someone to
anthropomorphize in in ways that are
problematic like right you have to look
at the world from a jellyfish point of
view to answer the question about
jellyfish and I doubt that jellyfish if
they could understand what suffering was
would define what they experience is
suffering but if they could understand
what suffering was they wouldn't be
jellyfish that is for sure though for
and for a long time we didn't think that
any organisms except for humans could
suffer which was like just just I feel
like willful yes right it seems like
like the kind of thing that you would
only believe because it's extremely
convenient to believe it speaking of
which Hank I have written a I am back
pentameter couplet about my height
I'm fairly sure I used to be 6:1 but doc
reports the shrinking has begun I'll be
here all week I mean why don't we just
read a short poem from John Green every
week oh yeah easier quality well you
know what I like most about them John
what the two lines long and that they
end and then I'm like ah good that was
good
listen I tried to cut the weekly short
poem and then people got really mad yeah
I mean it's good it's good I'm sorry I
have some really good advice for Lizzy
who asks dear Hank and John actually she
says dear Hank and also John just mmm to
the side there I've been trying my best
to keep my Tupperware cabinet tidy but
somehow every time I open the cabinet
the containers end up recklessly strewn
throughout why do different brands have
slightly different sized containers that
make them so difficult to stack should I
invest in some sort of organizational
device to buy or larger tubs to put my
tubs in seeing that you guys have been
adulting for much longer than I have and
you have kitchens of your own I assume
that you have run into a similar crisis
any advice would be appreciated always
covered in Tupperware Lizzie Lizzie here
is the thing you need to do throw out
all of your Tupperware this is wrecked
this is the biggest moment in your life
realizing you are an adult throw in the
way throw it away ray should go first
target buy a $15.00 36 piece Tupperware
set and they will all fit together
because they will be the same brand do
not save do not save the little
containers that your deli meat comes in
and say oh this is clearly meant to be a
youth reusable container don't do it go
to the deli get the little plastic bag
deli meat it's better anyway don't just
use the one kind of Tupperware get one
inexpensive Tupperware set and use that
and then after five years when it breaks
down because it was cheap get another
one okay as usual Hank is one third
correct
Hank is correct is that right now before
you even get to the end of this podcast
you need to throw away all of your
mismatched Tupperware it is a source of
tremendous anxiety and just wretchedness
throw it out throw all of it out Hank
was right about that he's wrong about
everything else what you need to do is
you need to call your local Thai
restaurant well I don't know if they do
delivery hopefully they do if not you're
gonna have to go to the restaurant and
pick it up and you're gonna order your
favorite dish every night for the next
26 nights in a row
and then the amazing thing is that you
will have 26 identical medium-sized
Tupperware containers with 26 identical
medium sized lids and all of your
problems will be solved forever well you
got to make sure that it's the kind of
classy place that puts it in a
Tupperware and not in one of those fold
each I knees food boxes because that's
my topic yes we obviously you have to
make sure of that in advance but once
you've so you just what you do is you
just start ordering takeout from various
restaurants until you get the correct
size Tupperware container and then you
go back to that restaurant 26
consecutive nights until you have 26
sets of Tupperware boom done I mean it
strikes me that you think you're saving
money but literally a Tupperware set of
like a 36 piece cup Tupperware set cost
less than two of those meals right but
you get 26 how many I can't remember how
many I said let's say 26 you get 26
amazing meals in the interim it's
totally worth it and then you've got an
amazing story when people are like hey
where'd you get all that incredibly well
matched toughie where you can say oh I
just ordered from sawasdee Thai
restaurant 26 consecutive days that's
our look at Thai restaurant by the way
it's excellent it didn't sponsor today's
podcast but I highly recommend it yeah
our local Thai restaurant is called
Sawadee which i think is probably the
same phrase but slightly different
grammar I don't know I don't know but
it's very good if you ever chair have a
chance to go there 86th and ditch really
solid times everything in Indianapolis
is it the same intersection almost
everything is that the intersect
of 86th and ditch I had a difficult
scene of The Fault in Our Stars occur at
the intersection of 86th and ditch
because I was sitting at the
intersection of 86th and ditch at the
Starbucks while I was writing it and I
thought where could they go and I looked
across the street and I was like oh they
could go to that gas station that's good
my book takes place in New York City so
I always have a tab that's just the
street view of New York City open just
like walking around where they're
walking around I remember that
James Joyce when he was writing Ulysses
he used to write two friends in Dublin
because he my god my back my friends in
Dublin and say hey could you do me a
solid and walk this exact route and then
write back to me about how long it took
what you saw and what the road was like
all right we got a nod this one comes
from Abigail who writes dear John I
think I work two jobs one is an
overnight job three days a week the
other is a daytime job two days a week
oh god yeah I've been doing this for two
weeks now in the transition between
sleeping at night and sleeping during
the day is rough my body is very
confused all the time
any advice writing this at 3:00 a.m.
because that's when my lunch hour is
Abigail
I mean Abigail this is not how the human
body is designed to operate there is no
way to fix this I mean there may it may
be a sustainable situation for some
people it may be a situation that you
just need to be in right now but that is
gonna be rough I think moving forward I
had an overnight job for several months
working at the Steak and Shake in Winter
Park Florida and even that messed a lot
I thought with with my brain it is
really hard to work third shift now I
have a cousin who's been doing it for
like 30 years and hold on hold on it's
coming nope it's not oh god I need to
sneeze so badly and it didn't happen
from that time oh now I'm just
frustrated I want to go back in time and
work harder to get that sneeze out but
now the moment has passed
anyway I have a cousin who's been doing
it for like 30 years and swears by it
and
says that it allows him to spend way
more time with his kids and do all kinds
of stuff I could not do it so different
people have different needs I guess but
I just don't think that there is a way
to make that not suck
I agree John I do not have good advice
so I'm going to move to the next
question
but after but only after commiserating
and saying keep going keep just keep
swimming little fish man you are we
would just be a terrible motivational
speaker that that's something a Finding
Nemo just yep dear Hank and John this is
from Maria I have a serious question
about hangers what's the right way to
hang a hanger with the hanger hook
facing the wall or the hanger hook
facing you I just painted my mom's
closet and we are in the process of
refilling it with her clothes and she
wants to hang all the hangers of the
hook facing the wall and I believe you
should hook facing you and the answer is
appreciated
Bulgaria here soon Maria is that also a
joke from Avatar The Last Airbender I
assume that that's an avatar the last
airbender thing because at this point we
can't risk it not being we got I have
never received so many letters as I did
about our failure to understand the
avatar the last airbender joke wait stop
wait stop I googled it it's it's
Bulgaria here's some to milk a male goat
okay oh oh it's like it's a phrase to
like attempt an impossible thing
different interaction Maria let's get
back to your question immediately Maria
here's here's the deal and I feel bad
about this because you're obviously a
nice person the hook faces the wall oh
yeah no you're super wrong about this
Maria this is yeah like think about it
if you have your like disco pants and
you want to party down and your party
pants and they're like it it's time to
go party you don't want to be like
flipping them out and pushing them
toward the wall and then bring them to
you see
you can go to your disco party and have
you disco jams correct - you need pants
now no yeah so the whole idea behind
getting your disco pants as quickly as
possible is just lift and pull the way
that you're proposing it involves
lifting pushing going down and then
pulling that's four motions by the time
that you're done with that the party is
probably over that's terrible yeah I
mean this is actually similar to the
long-standing argument it's one of the
longest pages on Wikipedia about whether
you should put toilet paper rolls so
that they face out or like you have to
come from underneath and to me it's so
obvious that it's not worth debating but
then also you know we only have this one
brief precious flicker of consciousness
and I am glad that some people are
choosing to spend it with me thinking
about the stuff that doesn't matter but
that I can't stop thinking about anyway
I mean it's weird to me that either of
these things could at all be debatable
the only reason to hang your toilet
paper not facing so that it's easiest to
get to is if you have a cat that does
the thing where it spins it down because
if you do it the other way the cat can't
spin the whole toilet paper out or you
only read with enemies and you want to
make their lives harder like I mean
that's that's the argument that I've
seen for it that actually makes some
sense if you're trying to like push
somebody out of your house you're just
trying make something a little ways to
communicate to your roommate that this
relationship has come to an end that
that kind of thing really really works
like putting the hangers in backwards
toilet paper head backwards I think
that's like the universal sign for it's
time to leave Phil if your roommates
consistently hang your toilet paper
could incorrectly then you maybe need to
find a new living situation alright this
next question comes from Madi who writes
Dear John and Hank why is there why is
there a fruit called a grapefruit when
there's already a fruit called a grape
sign-off Maddie this is an excellent
question because it isn't a grape
root a grape because it is a grape fruit
ah yes well it isn't a grapefruit
because it looks and tastes absolutely
nothing like a grapefruit yeah do you
know the etymology of the word
grapefruit no in fact I was about to
look it up it comes from the words grape
and the word fruit this is not a shock
do you want to know a few interesting
facts about grapefruits I want to know
more about the freaking etymology of
grapefruit okay they okay because
grapefruits grow in clusters and people
thought the clusters that grapefruits
grow in what kinds of kind of like
gigantic clusters of gigantic grapes in
clusters have you seen it's just like an
orange tree it's the same as an orange
tree Hank yep I am telling you what
Wikipedia which is never wrong since oh
god oh wait some other people think that
it might be because um it the Latin name
is citrus grandis meaning great citrus
or great fruit and then people just
mispronounced it that is I wouldn't be
shocked if there was some kind of like
both of those things had an effect on
this okay can I tell you some
interesting facts about grapefruits
mm-hmm well that's too bad because I've
done quite a lot of research and there
are no interesting facts about grapes
please send us Hank and Jonna gmail.com
you are interesting grapefruit facts we
can share them next week because we are
incapable of finding anything at all
even remotely interesting about this
fruit I don't think anybody's gonna find
anything good Godspeed my friends this
question comes from the book Ullman dear
John and Hank oops it's a dear Hank and
John I know that successful football and
soccer teams must replace their players
with better ones to improve but if
overtime all the players have been
replaced and AFC Wimbledon will it still
be the AFC Wimbledon team if it's not
about the players but the location why
do teams compete if you and I were just
to hire chess players to play against
each other in chess and my player won it
wouldn't prove anything about my chess
skills how is that different with sports
teams best wishes from the ship of
theseus The Bookman in Cleveland I mean
this is a great question and it gets to
the heart of the problem with franchises
which is that ultimately a sports
franchise is owned by usually by one
single rich person or one single rich
family and if they want to move the team
they can and the definition of the team
is the thing owned by that rich family
yeah interesting and the whole ship for
those who aren't familiar with the ship
of theseus the the basic idea is this a
ship takes off from port and the the
mast breaks so they replaced the mast
with a different piece of wood and then
all the other parts of the ship slowly
break over a long journey and they
replace all the other parts and then by
the time it gets back to port it is an
entirely different ship but at the same
time it is the same ship because and and
this question is applied to a lot of
problems especially problems with self
you know like if you start out as one
person as any and you end up as a
different person then are you still the
same person but also football teams I
guess so I think the answer in AFC
Wimbledon's case is actually relatively
straightforward which is that the
football club is the community that is
based around it which is why when the
English FA decided to move Wimbledon FC
to Milton Keynes it did not mean that
Milton Keynes suddenly had Wimbledon and
and then Wimbledon restarted as AFC
Wimbledon and even though they went from
the third tier to the ninth tier
overnight they were still the same
Football Club they still had the same
history they were still the same
community they still had the same
supporters and that's a lot of what I
find so interesting about the AFC
Wimbledon story is that at a time when
the social order said to these people
you don't have a football club anymore
they responded no we still have the same
football club we always have and then by
the force of their will and their
determination as a community eventually
the authorities the social order itself
was forced
to be like our bad you were right you do
still have the same football team and I
find that very very beautiful so I think
like in the end a good organization any
good community it is defined by the
people who are inside of it and they
change over time and that changes the
community over time but hopefully there
is some level of continuity that allows
the ship of theseus to still be the same
ship when it gets back to port well
which gets to the the very thing that
that like sort of solves the Ship of
Theseus riddle which is that it's not
about the ship it's about our imagining
of things brand and it is like that is
really the interesting thing about the
AFC Wimbledon's story is that like it
wasn't about like the team it's about
the people who enjoy it and who make up
the community and I feel that the same
way about like this podcast and about
all of the stuff that we make on the
internet that it's like like it is the
defined by the people who appreciate the
thing and imagining that and
understanding that makes that a much
more rich thing to be doing right
exactly yeah I mean you've got to
understand when you're part of a
community but especially when you're
leading a community like that that so
much does really depend on the way we
imagine the world like that's uh the
story that my new book gets its title
from the turtles all the way down story
is ultimately a story about
understanding that the world is in part
the stories we tell about it which leads
us to our sponsor this week which is
Turtles all the way down Turtles book by
John Green coming to a bookstore near
you available for pre-order in lots of
different places but only signed if you
go and figure out which ones are gonna
be signed if you could have probably
signed Turtles calm and just to
emphasize one thing the book comes out
on October 10th and it will be available
wherever books are sold and also some
places where you might not traditionally
look for books like Costco at today's
podcast is also of course brought to you
by the suffering of jellyfish the
suffering of jellyfish complicated this
podcast is also brought to you by the
inconsistent object that is yourself
you are being constantly replaced and
your bones that once where your bones
aren't actually your bones they're new
bones you and lastly this podcast is
brought to you by grapefruit originally
a great fruit now just a grapefruit used
to be great now that's a pretty good
that is the only interesting grapefruit
fact is that it possibly used to
originally be known as the grapefruit
it's a big fruit like how many how many
fruits are fruits by size fruits by size
what are the biggest fruits John
watermelon has to be the biggest fruit
right mmm I mean I'm not gonna pretend
to be an expert in this field I I don't
even really have a guess
I bet pumpkin is the biggest fruit nope
nope weighing 268 pounds well nope nope
nope that's wrong that's wrong it's
wrong John John help save me what's your
order what's your first of the week go
alright oh yeah I haven't I haven't used
it yet oh that is amazing an amazing
hint John I'm still gonna be fine I'm
still gonna win I'm not even worried
have you used yours I'm not gonna tell
you of course no absolutely not
Hank before we get to some more
questions from our listeners I really
have to read this vitally important
response some of you may remember that
in the past episode of the pod somebody
wrote in to say that they had been
harboring a secret snake in their home
and that they wanted to take the secret
snake to college but they couldn't
figure out how to get the snake to
college because their parents were going
with them on the drive so Devon and
Draco wrote back in to say Dear John and
Hank back in episode 87 you answered my
question about owning a secret snake as
of 7:00 p.m. Friday September 22nd 2017
one year and nine days after I got him
Draco is no longer secret my dad was
like I was worried about that with the
plot twist there was gonna be I know I I
too thought he might die but no my dad
discovered him while looking for our cat
who is a basement okay good I'm glad
that
cat wasn't in draco while he is not
thrilled that there has been a secret
snake in the house for one year and nine
days wait wait wait you didn't take the
snake to college you just left the snake
at home this right I have I have more
questions than answers did he leave the
snake at home to fend for himself ha or
did he
in the end just decide to take a
semester off from college to delay the
inevitable well he is not so we don't
know the answer to that question but we
do know this while he is not thrilled
that there is a snake in the house I
played my dad the segment from your
podcast and he found it hilarious and
Draco is allowed to stay although I have
been warned that there will be a
tarantula in my bed if he gets loose as
John said in his answer everything
turned out better than expected snakes
and secrets but no longer secret snakes
Devon and Draco John the world's largest
pumpkin which is the largest fruit ever
recorded was 1689 pounds also seven
hundred and sixty-six kilograms for
those of you who don't know what pounds
are alright well there you go a question
that I've never wanted the answer to and
now have the answer to well that's too
bad because my entire video this week is
gonna be a belt world's largest fruits
oh my god I don't even think you're
kidding you're desperate for a video
topic let me make a suggestion here's a
video topic my brother's first book in
six years comes out in ten days everyone
buy it at bookstores everywhere all
right we got another question Hank this
one comes from Anna who writes Dear John
and Hank when you see someone doing
something on snapchat is it weird to
talk about it when you next see them in
real life i watch my friends snapchats
and sometimes i feel like i should reply
but then it feels awkward when I do also
sometimes want to bring up their last
snap in conversation but always
chickened out at the last second so my
question is is it socially acceptable to
talk about social media in real life or
reply to something they posted hours ago
also another question why is chicken out
the phrase for not doing something or
being a wimp I mean what did chickens
ever do we tons of them every year so
shouldn't we just lay off any advice
would be appreciated as a great point
Anna I mean haven't we done enough to
chicken time just by eating them by the
billions
why do we also have to besmirch their
good name oh yeah I'm totally on board
with not no longer besmirching a chicken
to cease this did the besmirched mint of
chickens that's my new t-shirt yeah now
secondly I am so glad that you came to
two men who are in their late thirties
early forties to discuss with you how to
properly socially interact with people
who you who you are friends with and
follow on social media snapchats because
yeah we are the experts on how to
navigate the awkward world of knowing
what your friends are doing all of the
time yeah but not because you talked
about it that is correct you could not
have picked two better people for this
topic and as an expert ie someone who
last sent a snapchat in 2016 I feel
extremely prepared to tell you that it
is fine to talk in real life about
someone's most recent snaps as long as
you aren't sort of like overbearing
about it like it'd be great if you said
like I thought that was really funny the
caption and or emoji and or handmade
drawing that you did but it's not cool
if you talked about it for like 14
minutes and you detail all of the things
that you loved about the snap and how
you saved it and now it's you're like a
saver on your phone and everything yeah
like the thing that I the my experience
of snapchat and Instagram stories is
often like oh my friends are having yeah
and so there is a certain amount of like
navigating the eye like oh that was
really funny versus why wasn't I invited
to that thing that you did right not
everybody can be invited to everything
all the time and now we all know every
time we're missing out on something
which is not how it was a few years ago
you didn't know when your friends hung
out and you weren't there and that was
the thing that happened but you didn't
have to know about it all the time
Hank Hank can I ask you something do you
ever feel like you know that Simpsons
reference where Abe Simpson Homer's
father is holding a
newspaper with the headline old man
yells at cloud yeah yeah she's on the
newspaper yeah old man yells at cloud oh
that's what it is right I do feel like
an old man yelling at a cloud yeah I've
been a lot of different circumstances
sometimes I feel like I'm yelling at a
cloud and it's like it's like late stage
capitalism I mean right and sometimes I
feel like I'm yelling at a cloud and
it's like boy Hank just does not know
what this thing is and he's kind of
angry at something he does not
understand these young people these days
yeah I mean I remember being a kid and
just feeling like like old people were
completely deeply profoundly out of
touch about what was interesting like
even in my 20s I remember just thinking
like oh my god how does someone let
themselves get so far removed from what
is interesting about right now yeah and
now I'm like I am so uninterested and
what is interesting right now ya know
that's how I feel - it's freaking me out
yeah there's a lot of stuff to be
interested in and I think that it's
important to uh to be okay with both
yourself and with other people for being
and what they're interested in yeah and
that's gonna mean that I'm not very good
at Instagram stories well I'm actually
truly going to give Instagram stories
the old college try when we go on tour
because I like that that to me is what
is when I can use it to make sense have
it makes sense for me is when we're like
out and doing something because usually
my life is so boring and repetitive but
I really like its repetition but I don't
think that it would make for an
interesting Instagram story for me to be
like once again at 3:20 I did pick up my
children from school you know for the
like 19th consecutive week day I spent
the hours between 320 and 340 in the car
with the kids and be really maybe
there's like a certain set of people who
just want that very steady rhythmic
therapeutic Instagram story where it's
just the same thing every weekday right
yeah I mean like there is there is
benefit to that right like I
I don't know I like I like the classical
music station in Indianapolis partly
because they play the same like eight
pieces of classical music alright and
it's time to get to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon what's the news from
Mars this week Oh John remember last
week when we were talking about how
there was that group of people in Hawaii
who had gone out and they'd like hung
out for four months in Hawaii and it
went pretty well and nobody got super
angry well it turned out one of them
killed another one of them not away what
happened no not what ho oh wow you had
me for a second now I'm back to being
bored no no though one of them did get
interviewed and he said you know there's
rough moments that the hardest part they
said was the fact that they could not
just get on the internet like a normal
and if they were solving a problem and
needed information it would take days
when it should have taken minutes
because you wait for so long for
responses from people or a Google and so
that that is it definitely a problem to
solve but he said that there was not a
single insult not a single personal
insult hurled through the entire I don't
know if it was six or eight month long
experience but that's not my news the
news is that the UAE the United Arab
Emirates is apparently attempting to
build a 100 million pound Martian city
that's the currency unit not the weight
in the Emirati desert to simulate life
on the Red Planet
Wow yeah 1.9 million square feet largest
space simulation city ever built largest
largest bio dime dome ever team of
researchers will live in the city for a
year carry out experiments to understand
life on Mars and it will have a museum
open to the public whose walls will be
3d printed from the sand and it is
unclear when the building would building
will begin on the project or its exact
location so who knows if it's actually
gonna be a thing that will exist with
this Mars Science City they've got some
cool 3d renders of it it looks pretty
and they have so much money in the UAE
they can do these weird things yeah
I mean that's the only Mars I'll ever
visit I'm just gonna tell you that right
now
that's gonna be my number one all-time
favorite Mars that I visit in my
lifetime is the Mars right here on earth
mm-hmm I mean it looks pretty cool Hank
can you hear that that that in the
background mmm it's a rumbling it's a
rumbling noise I hear no no it's the sad
string quartet music oh oh yes it's sad
it's like a it's like it's like an
ambulance riding away no not exactly
it's sadder than that it's it's the only
thing sadder than that it's the sound of
having lost a home game against milton
keynes two-nil
there were many wonderful moments almost
all of them in the stands with wimbledon
fans singing who were you who were you
who were you when you were us my
all-time favorite chant in any in any
sport but the moments on the pitch were
not great I watched the whole game live
on the AFC Wimbledon app there's some
issues with the live streaming but it is
much better than no live streaming and
it was really really really frustrating
I was yelling at my phone which I try
very hard never to do I really it was
really frustrating and I feel terrible
for all of the Wimbledon fans out there
because that's the one game that you
really want to win in a season and it
was difficult and also Wimbledon did not
score and Wimbledon spent essentially
the entire game in the attacking half of
a field and the only two times that
Milton Keynes had anything like an
attack they scored and then Milton and
then Wimbledon went on to lose to
Southend United on September 26th which
is very bad and was a game that we
really should have won and now we find
ourselves in what can own at this point
I think it is fair to describe the
situation as perilous there are 46 games
in the season we're only through ten of
them so it is not yet a period for panic
however Wimbledon in ten games have
scored five goals
that is not great and they are only one
spot away from the relegation zone and
only kept out of the relegation zone by
goal difference so it has not been a
bright beginning to the year I do know
however what your phrase of the week was
well I mean it's not fair because it in
a bit that Hank I got like halfway
through a bit and Hank was like we have
to cut that because you already did it
and then I redid string quartet and of
course he's gonna know so yes it was
string quartet III I lost this week and
I'm mad about it was your phrase born
this way no no no I thought that I was
just talking about disco pants for no
reason Oh God disco pants is so
perfectly specific God how could I not
have noticed that all of the listeners
are gonna be flooding my Twitter with
comments about how I clearly wasn't
paying attention to be fair I'm not
really paying attention but regardless
Hank thank you for padmi we now have to
go over to our patreon patreon complex
dear Hank and John to record this
weekend Ryan which has become a podcast
that is about everything except for
people named Ryan ah but III do
appreciate you being here Hank and
enlivening my days and giving me
something to think about other than the
turtles all the way down situation well
I don't look forward to these days when
this will happen to me but I also really
do and I'm really excited for your book
to come out and and I hope that there's
excitement among your anxiety because
it's very good and I can't wait for
people to read it now thanks man I
appreciate it this podcast is produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
Victoria buongiorno as our head of
community and communications our music
is by the brilliant gunnarolla you can
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
or find us on Twitter at Hank green or
at John Green thank you again for
listening and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]